Alright. So that's all the algorithms that we're
going to talk about in terms of unsupervised clustering algorithms.
But I would like to kind of pop up
a level, and talk a little bit about different
properties that clustering algorithms might have. Desirable properties. So,
the three that I'm going to talk about are richness.
Scale-invariance and consistency, and these are good things to
have right? I'd like to be rich and consistent.
>> And Lord knows, you'd like to be scale-invariant.
>> I would. I wish I were scale-invariant.
I guess it would be very hard for me to gain weight if that were true.
>> Mm-hm. No matter what the scale is, the number's always the same.
>> Alright, so if you have a clustering algorithm, what does it do? It
takes a set of distances d and maps them to a set of clusters.
>> Or partitions.
>> Right. Or a partition. Right. And these
are three properties of those kinds of mappings.
So richness is the idea that for any
assignment of objects to the clusters, there's some distance
matrix that would cause your clustering algorithm to produce
that clustering. For any clustering that you want to
achieve there is some distance matrix where p of
d, your clustering algorithm, your clustering scheme, produces that clustering.
>> So that's like saying, all inputs are valid and all outputs are valid.
>> All inputs, which is to say
that the distance matrices, sure, those are valid,
and anything could be an output. Any way
of clustering could be an output. because the,
you know, think of the alternative. The alternative is there are certain
clusters that you just can't produce. And that seems wrong, doesn't it?
That, it ought to be the case that your clustering algorithm should
produce whatever is appropriate, and shouldn't
be limited in what it can express.
>> Sometimes. You'd even want your algorithms to
say, you know what, there's only one cluster here.
>> Yeah. I mean, totally. If I showed you
a picture, you might look at it. And you'd
say I just see one cluster and it looks
like a cloud. The second property that we're talking about,
the scale invariance. And this is, I think, much
more straight forward, at least in terms of conceptually.
So, it just means that if I give you
a distance matrix and I double all the distances
or halve all the distances. It shouldn't change what
the clustering is. That the clustering algorithm should be
invariant to what the space of the point is,
assuming that we keep the relative distances the same.
>> So this is the NASA problem. So this says that, if I
come up with a bunch of clusterings because I've been measuring points in miles,
if I suddenly start measuring them in kilometers, it shouldn't change anything.
>> That's right, yeah, change of units. Yeah, that's a really
good way of thinking about it. It's not even that I'm
scaling the distances, I'm just using inches instead of feet. It
should be the case that it's still the same data. All
right. And then the last one is maybe the hardest one
to visualize. But, it's a really reasonable thing. And you would
expect clustering to act this way. So, consistency says that if
we have some clustering. If your clustering algorithm produces some clusters.
So, let's, let's do a little example of that. Then, shrinking the
intracluster distances and expanding the intercluster
distances, does not change the clustering.
Let me show you that. All right. And now I've edited this
so that within the clusters the points have gotten closer together. More
so in this one than, than the other. Or not changing them
at all. But in this particular case, I shrunk this one a
lot, I shrunk this one a little. And then I moved the
clusters a little bit farther apart. This changes the distances a bit and
we like our clustering algorithm to continue
to consider these clusters, right? It shouldn't introduce
new clusters because we've shrunken things. And
it shouldn't want to join these things together,
because they've gotten further apart. So, that's
this notion of consistency and a little bit
more cumbersome to describe, but very natural
thing to think about in the clustering setting.
>> Well that makes sense right? So, this is where our
domain knowledge comes in so, distances are a measure of similarity, right?
>> Yup.
>> So,
what consistency says if you found that a bunch of things were similar
and a bunch of other things were dissimilar. That if you made the things
that were similar, more similar and the
things that were not similar, less similar.
It shouldn't change your notion which things
are similar and which things are not.
>> Yeah, which things are alike, which
things want to be grouped together. Yeah, uh-huh.
>> Hm.
>> Good so you think you understand these three clustering ideas?
>> I believe I do.
>> Alright, so let's put them into play a little bit.
>> Okay.